Creativity is not simply original thinking, after all both of these paragraphs
are equally original. They're both unusual and both give voice to sentences
that are probably never been uttered or written before these writers penned
them. So, for something to be deemed creative however, it must not only be
original, but it also must be useful and adaptive and solve a problem. James
Joyce's paragraph does that, because it's part of solving the problem of
telling a story. The second paragraph is not creative, because it's not useful.
It doesn't solve a problem. By useful, we clearly do not mean pragmatic. James
Joyce's novel was useful in the sense that he was the first novelist to write
from the perspective of inside a person's unconcious mind. It has been so
esteemed and deemed creative by experts and readers of English literature
because it presented a powerful study of unconscious human thought and emotion.
It can be useful in a literary, artistic, or aesthetic sense, in that people
are inspired by it and make use of it in their own creations. The second quote,
is equally as original but does not solve an important problem. In any useful
or adaptive way. By itself, these phrases may be interesting but together,
they're not terribly coherent. Or were not made with the intent of shedding
light on the inner workings of a human mind as was "Ulysses". So. Creative
thought and behavior requires two things. Originality or novelty of the thought
and behavior, and that thought and behavior has to be useful and adaptive
solution to some kind of problem. So new forms of art and literature,
architecture, science technology, and business changed their fields. The field
is different after the insight or innovation. Creativity changes things for the
better. Of course the usefulness, our originality may not be immediately seen
or appreciated. Truly creative thought, behavior may be well ahead of it's
time. So the evaluation of creativity is not limited to the here and now.